freunde herzlich willkommen zu diesem
video einen tag persönlicher koch für
einen sternekoch und nicht irgendeinen
sondern für maximilian lorenz ich darf
ich heute einen tag lang gerochen und du
hast mir gar keine aufgaben gegeben das
heißt ich durfte meine kreativität
freien lauf lassen bist du aufgeregt
wie ich habe ich habe einfach sein das
muss lecker sein das muss gut und ich
haben gewissen anspruch der natürlich
irgendwo hier oben steht ich wünsche
viel spaß dabei leute ich habe angst und
es geht auch direkt spannend los mit
breakfast kurs setzt kommen so wir
starten mit dem frühstück als aller
erstes werde ich mich um die theorie so
kümmern ich habe extra eine feurige
genommen bei ich ja auch ein bisschen
was abgeben wenn wir das ganze heute
essen die so schön zusammen ich werde
die glaube ich aus ihrer haut befreien
bevor ich sie anbraten bleibt da noch
ein bisschen klein wird auf den
verletzten ist auch zur iso sehr wichtig
ich hatte überlegt das ganze mit bacon
zu machen aber ich glaube es gibt auf
jeden fall noch mal diesen texmex weib
und ich glaube es macht noch mal
deutlich interessanter und unsere
theorie so kommt jetzt einfach über in
unsere fahne gibt überhaupt kein extra
ölfeld sonst was dran weil so viel wie
das ist ihr seht warten wir einmal durch
zum palais tomaten ich habe hier zwei
gekauft eine kurze beine nicht köln
wirft tomate die sind übertrieben weil
ich dich beim hofladen gekauft und ich
glaube wirklich dass die differenz sind
deshalb freue ich mich da auch sehr
drauf und
richtig saftig und daraus machen wir
jetzt einen kleinen tomatensalat also
einfach beides zusammen ein bisschen öl
bisschen seit das kommt dann mit auf
unsere tacos drauf einfach grob würfeln
eigentlich sollten wir sollten
vielleicht mag es auch mal verkabeln
besser ist es oder so jetzt gehe ich die
tomaten einmal in eine schüssel noch ein
bisschen aufgeregt ich will dich nicht
so also funktionen herausforderung heute
muss natürlich sagen ich glaube das ist
doch asozial wenn ich dir einfach genau
gegenüber sitze wie sie hier so beim
koch bei der gesellenprüfung was macht
er jetzt macht man das mutig
ich finde es ja schon mal cool dass du
hast du gesagt hast du machst du hast
und dann auch noch zu sagen geht so ich
habe jetzt irgendwie nicht sag ich mal
meinen freund der christian der ist koch
seit 20 jahren aber eigentlich jetzt
investmentbanker sonst würde sagen 30
einfach ins höchste regalreihen ja das
ist jetzt schon angebraten das heißt wir
machen hier immer aus den herd tor aus
acht hat jetzt schon relativ viel öl ab
wie mache ich das wirklich mein held
drin die jury sagen jetzt raus geholt
jetzt gebe ich doch das fett aus der
pfanne raus weil sagt ehrlich wir wollen
lieber so ein klassen cremiges rühre ich
glaube das passt auch besser dann
einfach zu der theorie sie dann jetzt
bevor wir weiter machen ein paar eier
behältnis schon mal sechs eier um die
macher allerdings nicht mehr darauf
haben bevor wir uns eingehend mit mir
erst mal alles weitere vor bereichen
hast du schon mal was von mir lernen
jetzt mal wie man das schnell großartig
tun aber in grobe würfel gehen wir dann
später einfach so drauf deshalb auch
eine gemüsezwiebel nicht ganz so scharf
aber trotzdem noch mal interessant auf
jeden fall mehr brauchen wir gar nicht
gemerkt übrigens leute wie
experimentieren heute bisschen mittwoch
kein voiceover einfach weil wir gemerkt
haben paar von euch gegen das meer paar
von euch lieben das meer und
dementsprechend gucken wir mal was uns
am besten mit vokal bestehen die herren
raus sind dann einfach so filets
rausschneiden auch wieder den herd an
eine kurzwahl werden hier drüben macht
jetzt auch an weil da werden wir die
tortillas jetzt kurz einmal warm machen
warum natürlich einen guten sticht
vorteil ist in unserer fahne wir machen
so topf scramble text also sollen nicht
so hart werden sondern schön fein und
weich und dafür ist mir ganz viel
bewegung drin es sei eigentlich das
geheimrezept der französischen küche
lieben würden die tore tore tore das
heißt wahrscheinlich so viel ich kann
mich einfach sehr lecker ich kenne auch
kein französisches mussten meine
ausbildung jedes mal anhören butter
sozusagen unter zeit zeit zeit viel fett
und ganz viel ruhe und dann wird das
schon gut freien mit unserem alt und
jetzt ganze zeit bewegen ist mehr als so
ganz haben zur optischen wunder wir
machen den nächsten tagen fertig als
wird mit frauen leute so nehmen wie
jetzt das nur herunter das stück noch
ein bisschen in der pfanne aber das hat
man gute konsistenz
so max hier sitzen die beiden märkte
jetzt also brett für stars stories für
lokale und noch ein paar kleine extras
beziehung glas orangensaft ich hoffe
dass wir die schmecken ich finde schon
mal super dass man dass man frühstück
kreativ lösen kann also nicht
irgendjemand so die stulle mit oder
rührei oder gene ahnung pochiertes ei
ich hab einfach zu sagen kennt man man
man nimmt diesen drift der jury zu
haufen man geht mit der avocado einfach
natürliches verein bringen man hat die
frische der tomate man hat ein bisschen
die schärfe der zwiebel aber eine
gesunde schärfe ja dann die gewünschte
schärfe der schweizer mit dem koriander
dass das könntest du auch durchaus ohne
weiteres als mieter nachts erst stimmt
also im prinzip haben muss gar kein
frühstück nein aber das ist ja auch so
ein bisschen was deutsch ist dass man
morgens nur kalt und brot essen ja
einfach mal rein was ist wird so unschön
aus du kannst gerne das ringen hat nach
zunehmen und die er gemacht das war ich
als beim unterteller ich hol schon mal
das zebra und wird zu schief gehen
er blickt sieht gut aus
was ist dein und der textur vom
geschmack zu sagen er von hinten kommt
die scherte sehr gut durch das super
dass das lauwarme ist du brauchst die am
kabel um das um das 100 präsentieren
weil die schule schon sehr prägnant ist
das ruder ist der perfekt gelungen der
koriander ist der gewisse drückt die
tomaten jetzt gegen die frisch aber
haben tomaten geschmack der durchkommt
konnte ja ich möchte eigentlich gerne
weiter okay ist weiter wozu wir sehen
uns gleich zu bewerten
alles weg hoffentlich wirst du auch
gesetzlich ja du wärst nick war gut
thema bewertung des super die jury zu
sehr gut sehr scharf aber gut die
zwiebel tomaten hätte ein bisschen mehr
griff gebrauchen können vielleicht auch
weil er noch mit koriander spiel noch
ein bisschen mit einer avocado gut ein
anwendung oben drauf wäre vielleicht ein
meersalz oder einfach die avocado
abseits ja ja deswegen 95 von 10
ich finde er ich will werde ich dafür
heute wird wieder geschwitzt aber ich
meine ich nicht verstehe sehr dass man
ist sehr lecker fahne ist weil ich
wollte dass auch schon lange mal mach ja
du hast mir glücklicherweise gesagt ich
habe freie auswahl deshalb habe ich das
gemacht hat auch super lecker aber damit
können wir auf jeden fall arbeiten da
sehen wir uns für die serie zum
mittagessen jetzt lobster so leute wie
lange ich das schon machen und essen
wollte wir haben alles vor uns was wir
brauchen sehr bescheidenen zutaten 2
hommage wente man kann das ganze
natürlich auch mit einem ganzen humor
machen aber die waren jetzt einfacher zu
bekommen für mich dann haben wir hier
rosmarin und petersilie wir haben
brioche hot dog bands die man von oben
füllen kann sehr mais limette zitrone
sonst geht da gar nicht viel mehr ab wir
lassen den hunger für sich sprechen ist
auch gut auch immer legen wir hin dann
gehen wir mit dem messer am ende des
schwanzes einmal rein und lassen es nach
vorne kippen
klingt ein bisschen krass aber so können
wir das für ihn auf trennen und dann
sehen wir jetzt auch das fleisch was im
huma spanisch sitzt vielleicht machen
wir schnell mit dem anderen
so ich löse jetzt einmal mit den fingern
ein bisschen das fleisch hier vor nur
drunter gehen ihr merkt schon das ist
gar nicht super viel fleisch also
nochmal anlocken so ein bisschen butter
gehe ich zur seite weil damit machen wir
gleich die kräuter botschaften ein wenig
schnitt wird kurz in der mikrowelle
anlagen ist gesprengt butter geschmolzen
ich suche jetzt hier noch ein bisschen
von petersilie rosmarin ich glaube ich
nur zum aromatisieren also den ruhig
dann wieder rauszieht viel butter ist es
vielleicht aber es gibt auch nicht zu
viel
zuviel mutter ein wenig knoblauch
granulat geben wir noch ein bisschen
butter über die homer schwänze damit dir
einfach gleich nicht so ankleben reicht
auch wenn wir das von der seite machen
wo das fleisch isst was ihr das hier
noch ein bisschen gleichmäßig drauf und
dann können wir gleich auflegen manchmal
auch mutter dann geht das ziemlich
fertig ist jetzt raus namen grill ich
habe hier die hunger schwänze macht den
ganzen laden hier einmal auf und wir
legen auf mich sehr schön gehört gleich
sehen da wo man kriegt jetzt gleich
seine charakteristische farbe dadurch an
der anderen seite stellen wir einfach
unsere kräuterbutter auch und wir machen
den allerersten mal zu und einfach mal
gucken was gut aussieht wir schauen
jetzt mal rein und so butter schmilzt
und wir legen jetzt schon direkt mal den
hunger die andere seite ihr seht es wird
jetzt schon dieses orangene wir sind
raum leute wir haben den sagt jetzt
schön den wollen wir uns auch bewahren
jetzt wollen wir das ganze wieder ein
und jetzt nehmen wir uns einfach einen
teelöffel viele hier einmal das fleisch
raus sagt
sehr sehr wild erstmals schneide ich
hier unseren hunger kleinen eineinhalb
zentimeter dicke stückchen jetzt nämlich
das ganze und gäbe es so wie es ist in
unserem butter hinein jetzt wird es
pervers leute allein das schon aussieht
das sieht doch schon einfach krass aus
jetzt kommt dazu nämlich mario marx hat
die unterscheidung unterstützt denn da
ist viel zucker drin und das macht sich
sogar relativ gut deshalb dürfen wir
jetzt vor den augen eines sternekochs
diesen skandal begehen wir dürfen das
ganze also offiziell zu machen und
würden das jetzt einmal durch den lass
uns noch ein bisschen marinieren kommen
jetzt auch noch ein bisschen salz
pfeffer dran die gebe ich jetzt auch
direkt in die mitte und zitrone waren
sind mehr limette bisschen weniger
zitrone was jetzt sehr schön ist dadurch
dass zu hell flüssigkeiten zugegeben hat
fängt wieder an zu regieren du hast ja
auch jetzt die flüssigkeit verdünnt zu
den fettgehalt und schaffte eine
emulsion ja das sieht man richtig teuer
wie das jetzt gerade wieder informiert
hammer ein wenig butter schmalz in
unsere fahne mutter geht auch habe noch
keine mehr sagt und da thorsten jetzt
ganz kurz einmal unsere freerolls an
[Musik]
das ist also unser gericht die lovestory
leute ich kann es nicht erwarten ihr
seht schon zwei gläser denn ich durfte
ist eigentlich nicht sagen das muss ich
mag es wirklich zugute halten er hat mir
großzügige gastgeschenke mitgebracht hat
dein eigener sekt und ich dachte mir
wenn wir das jetzt machen du musst ja
das sieht man ja hast du gut oder müssen
wir dazu schon reichen dekadent aber ja
es ist wirklich ein sehr dicker der das
essen auch die loks dieser noch nicht
kalt werden deshalb schlug er sich
besser aus mit wein als ich das muss ich
machen aufmachen eingießen trinken spaß
haben treten ich trinke mut für das
gericht ja
nicht gut aber max lasst uns das einmal
angucken wer will schon sehr simples
gericht ja kummer butter mario gewürze
und dazu eine schöne pre roll gab es
gibt gar nicht viel zu tun ein bisschen
sofres lösung ab
wo leute ich weiß noch dass immer essen
wollten das ist schon richtung stabiler
hin gegner haye wir sagen ganz schnell
wieder zurück muss das jetzt auch
probieren wir sehen uns wieder wirklich
leute es ist sind gefühlt zwei minuten
vergangen wir haben das klingt weg
geknallt aber es ging auch nicht anders
verhalten virgin was was das angegangen
jaja ich auch noch nicht gegessen aber
wenn ich in meiner welt mir vorstellen
müsste wie es in gut zu sein hat so also
das war das war fertigt das war seit
sich das war säure das war vom brot noch
mal zucker dieses angetastet für mich
jetzt vielleicht noch eine idee mehr
angetastet sein könnte einfach dass ich
noch ein bisschen kontrast das sehr sehr
weich ist ja aber dadurch hast diesem
aritkel also wenn du ein amerikaner sagt
irgendwie das ist schwarzbrot dass es
hart und ehrlich gesagt verstehe ich
nicht voll aber punktemäßig sie glaube
ich heute die 10 gefallen
klage habe wirklich ich habe es
vergessen und ich dachte mir das ist das
also für mich war das geilste was ist
dann gegessen hat das war wirklich krank
wenn ihr die gelegenheit habe ich weiß
das ist dekadent das ist teuer macht es
nach oder ansonsten einfach mit ganz
normalen kanälen feld zu direkt im preis
runter ich glaube die kriegt jeder von
euch im supermarkt und aber gleiche
geschichte mahjong ein roller mutter
genau sieht eigentlich sollte das video
jetzt hier enden ja aber ihr habt
vielleicht schon gesehen im hintergrund
kocht etwas zwar schicken adobe wir
sehen uns jetzt zum abendessen schicken
adoro das kennt wahrscheinlich viele von
euch nicht ich mache es auch zum ersten
mal aber ich habe viel davon gehört
damit werden wir den max auf jeden fall
überzeugen können wir haben ja unsere
zutaten acht hähnchenkeulen zementierten
und normalen schwarzem pfeffer und 20
knoblauchzehen klingt sehr viel dann
wenn wir noch ein paar zutaten aus dem
asiatischen supermarkt gehe ich gleich
darauf ein aber wir fangen erst mal an
und schnappen uns unsere 20
knoblauchzehen und hauen die einfach
platt nehme man eine fahne will dann
geht es schneller ein wenig backpapier
drüber und los geht's wir sehen stand
wird schön das macht alles da unten das
sieht gut aus und wir nehmen den
gesamten knoblauch eben den in unsere
schüssel hinein und dazu ganz einfach
unsere acht schenke dann kommen unsere
ganzen pfefferkörnern frisch gemahlener
pfeffer dann benötigen wir peilen zucker
50 gramm davon wir mögen wir 300
milliliter ungekürzten reis essig als
nächstes benötigen wir 60 milliliter von
der dunklen sojasauce das geht schon mal
in die richtige richtung wenn wir uns
das anschauen jetzt 120 milliliter
sojasauce kommt auch dazu 120 milliliter
wasser dazu kommen jetzt noch vier
lorbeerblättern mengen wir das ganze gut
durch das uns ganz kurz stehen werden
wir umbauen und können dann auch schon
anfangen das kicken an zu branchen wir
geben ein wenig erdnussöl in unseren top
schmeißen das ganze an und lassen uns
schön heiß werden bei mittlerer hitze
anbraten einfach nur in etappen alle
unsere hähnchenschenkel schön an dass
die farbe bekommen aber ansonsten leute
müssen wir das dann einfach nur noch
zurückgeben und einkochen auf eine
stunde ist das machen
[Musik]
so leute das chicken hannover ist durch
gekocht hat sich so viel getan in der
stunde in der das jetzt gekocht hat wir
haben wirklich glaube ich wäre das hier
ist mal ein bisschen drüber sprenkeln
über alles hier drüben ist unser reich
gekocht haben ist ja auch gut geworden
doch gut aus wirklich lecker und wir
machen das ganze jetzt gleich mit nichts
weiter als adobe und reis auf den teller
als felix
[Musik]
da stehen wir also vor dem schicken
adoro mit basmatireis ich habe noch ein
paar von unseren zitronen und limetten
von vorhin bereitgestellt und du merkst
selbstbewusst kein messer eigentlich
sollte das chicken relativ weich sein
jetzt sagt er jetzt sage ich jetzt und
ob's stimmt können wir glaube ich nur
auf eine art und weise herausfinden text
scheint zu funktionieren
da schon ganz ganz arg auf einmal noch
gerne aber wie dieses wort kommt denn
die säure muss man erst mal auf sich
wirken dass das ist jetzt nicht ohne
visum oder irgendwie denkst ja das
verstehst du sofort leute ich habe mir
das schon ein bisschen auf das wirken
insbesondere erkennt dass nämlich
wenigstens und stadt sehen und stellt
wieder zur bewertung bist du bedient
macht einen tag ich bin satt auf jeden
fall gleich noch irgendwo unterwegs ein
verdauungsschnaps ihr thema adobe ich
kannte es gar nicht das ist für mich
komplettes neuland es ist butterzart es
ist salzig es ist süß sauer es hat zu
diesen diesen humanitärer hilfe an der
reis und das hätte ich nicht gedacht hat
eine daseinsberechtigung als es nicht
nur fertigungsanlage es braucht halt
elementaren die soße aufzunehmen und er
hat selber noch was geschmückt also wenn
du jetzt wenn du sagst was du alles drin
hast du hättest vielleicht einfach auch
sag ich mal was weiß ich was
geräuchertes zu gehen können und das
geht unter schätzt du was ich bekomme ja
lasst uns gleichzeitig sagen ja 32 19
du warst du dich zu mir du warst ein
traumhafter gast du hast mir drei
flaschen wein geschenkt ich habe also
auf jeden fall heute noch was zu tun ich
mich nur bedanken checkt maximilian auf
jeden fall ab in der beschreibung und
verlinkt ich bin richtig happy mit dem
ergebnis heute es war alles lecker statt
spaß gemacht und ich konnte vor allem
einen sternekoch überzeugen oder wir
sehen uns im nächsten video wieder auf
68 bis dahin